en el vídeo anterior analizamos el
mecanismo para una reacción sn 2
en este caso el ión hidróxido funcionará
como un núcleo filo y atacara al electro
filo que es este carbono y como un
mecanismo sn 2 es un mecanismo
concertado el núcleo filo ataca al
electro filo al mismo tiempo que se va
el grupo saliente entonces el bromo se
va y se convierte en el ánimo bromuro y
el lo h es decir el núcleo fi lo
sustituye al grupo saliente así que en
nuestro producto final
ahora tenemos 1 h unido a nuestra cadena
de carbonos y en este vídeo veremos la
estéreo especificidad de una reacción s
n 2 eso significa que la estéreo química
del reactivo determina la estéreo
química del producto por ejemplo si
analizamos nuestro sustrato sabemos que
este carbono es un centro gira el bromo
está dibujado con esta cuña lo que
significa
que se encuentra hacia nosotros y la
configuración de este centro quiral es r
y si analizamos nuestro producto este es
nuestro centro que irá pero ahora
tenemos el o h
lejos de nosotros y la configuración en
este centro girar es ese así que la
estéreo química de nuestro producto es
determinada por la estéreo química del
reactivo porque este es un mecanismo sn
2 y observamos la inversión de la
configuración no escribir inversión de
la configuración pasamos de la
configuración r a la configuración s y
eso significa que el núcleo filo solo
puede atacar por el lado opuesto al que
se encuentra el grupo saliente y eso es
consistente con nuestro mecanismo sn 2
una forma de verlo es que si este bromo
es relativamente grande y tiene mucha
densidad electrónica a su alrededor
con todos estos pares
libres todo eso repele al núcleo filo
cargado negativamente así que nuestro
núcleo a filo tiene que atacar por el
lado opuesto al grupo saliente
por eso obtenemos la inversión de la
configuración ahora les mostraré un
vídeo usando el modelo molecular para
que vean cómo es que el r2 bromo butano
se convierte en ese 2 butano y espero
que puedan entenderlo mejor aquí tenemos
el r2 bromo bután he puesto el bromo de
color amarillo y no puse los hidrógenos
de los grupos al kilo para que lo
podamos ver mejor
entonces si volteo el modelo y
analizamos el centro quiral podemos ver
que tenemos una geometría tetra hedrick
a alrededor de este carbono
este es un metilo que está hacia
nosotros tenemos un hidrógeno lejos de
nosotros un estilo hacia abajo y el
bromo está hacia la derecha entonces
aquí tenemos el núcleo filo y el núcleo
filo
y atacar a este carbono entonces el ion
hidróxido se tiene que acercar al
sustrato por el lado opuesto a nuestro
grupo saliente veamos el estado de
transición observen que aún tenemos al
grupo metilo hacia nosotros al hidrógeno
lejos de nosotros al estilo hacia abajo
y al halógeno hacia la derecha pero
ahora se forma un enlace entre este
oxígeno y este carbono y también tenemos
un enlace parcial entre este halógeno y
el carbono ahora si analizamos ese
carbono podemos ver que los tres grupos
el metil el hidrógeno y el grupo de tilo
esos tres grupos están en el mismo plano
si rotamos la molécula un poco podemos
ver que todos están planos entonces en
el estado de transición se forma un
enlace al mismo tiempo que otro se rompe
y si mantengo este modelo del estado de
transición podemos compararlo con el
producto final este
es nuestro producto final el alcohol aún
tenemos el grupo metilo hacia nosotros
el hidrógeno lejos de nosotros
a la izquierda y el grupo de tilo hacia
abajo esta es una forma de representar
nuestro producto pero si rotamos un poco
el modelo para ver nuestra cadena de
carbonos ahora el grupo h está hacia
nosotros esa es otra forma de ver el
producto final y también si volteamos el
modelo ahora el o h está lejos de
nosotros y así es como lo dibujamos en
la reacción original dibujemos lo que
vimos en el vídeo el ión hidróxido
nuestro núcleo filo ataca a este carbono
al mismo tiempo que estos electrones se
van junto con el bromo dibujemos el
estado de transición pondré el corchete
y vamos a dibujar el h aquí tenemos un
par de electrones libres y vimos que se
forma un enlace parcial entre el oxígeno
y este carbono en él
le señalé que el grupo metilo aún se
encuentra hacia nosotros entonces el
grupo metilo está hacia nosotros el
hidrógeno lejos de nosotros y el grupo
de tilo se encuentra hacia abajo esas
tres cosas el grupo metilo el hidrógeno
y el grupo de tilo están en el mismo
plano y al mismo tiempo tenemos un
enlace parcial entre el carbono y el
grupo saliente que en este caso es el
bromo y pondré los electrones en el
bromo ok entonces este es el estado de
transición y podemos indicar que es un
estado de transición con este símbolo
ahora aquí el ión hidróxido tiene una
carga formal negativa pero como está
formando un enlace con este carbono
tiene una carga parcial negativa pierde
un poco de densidad electrónica conforme
se va formando el enlace y como los
electrones se van junto con el bromo
para formar el año en bromuro
tenemos una carga más negativa en el
bromo así que también le vamos a poner
una carga formal negativa entonces este
es el estado de transición en el que el
núcleo filo está formando un enlace al
mismo tiempo que el enlace con el grupo
saliente se está rompiendo y finalmente
dibujemos nuestro producto justo como lo
vimos en el vídeo vamos a dibujar el
grupo metilo hacia nosotros por eso lo
representamos con una cuña el hidrógeno
se encuentra lejos de nosotros y el
grupo etilo se encuentra hacia abajo ahí
está y ahora tenemos un enlace con él o
h
y así regresamos a la geometría te trae
drica entonces este carbono nuestro
centro que ir al empezó con una
geometría te trae drica y después aquí
con los tres grupos tenemos una
geometría plana pero para nuestro
producto final nuevamente regresamos a
la geometría tetraedro
y esta es una forma de dibujar nuestro
producto pero en el vídeo les enseñé que
si lo giramos un poco podemos ver la
cadena de carbonos así y ahora el grupo
o h está hacia nosotros y si volteamos
la molécula ahora la cadena de carbono
se ve así y él o h queda lejos de
nosotros entonces estas son tres formas
diferentes de representar el producto
que es el s2 butano veamos otra reacción
sn 2 con estéreo química y veamos el
producto primero podemos decir ok este
guión cargado negativamente debe ser el
núcleo filo y en el sustrato el alumno
de alquilo yo sé que el cloro retira
densidad electrónica de este carbono
porque es más electro negativo lo que
significa que este carbono tiene una
carga parcial positiva entonces el
núcleo filo ataca el electro filo al
mismo tiempo que estos electrones se van
con el cloro para formar el año
entonces ya sabemos lo que pasa en el
mecanismo sn 2 pero si ahora analizamos
la estéreo química
sabemos que el núcleo filo tiene que
atacar por el lado opuesto al grupo
saliente y que obtenemos una inversión
de la configuración entonces cuando
dibujamos el producto si dibujamos la
cadena de carbonos de la misma forma con
la que empezamos como el cloro está
representado con una línea punteada es
decir está lejos de nosotros entonces
vamos a mostrar el enlace con el núcleo
filo con una cuña porque se encuentra
hacia nosotros aquí tenemos el sh este
es nuestro producto final para sistemas
simples se encontrarán con la inversión
de la configuración si empezamos con un
compuesto r obtendremos la configuración
s y si empezamos con s obtendremos er
sin embargo no siempre tiene que ser así
si analizamos esta reacción de la
izquierdo tenemos el compuesto inicial
esta es una reacción sn 2 y en este caso
el núcleo filo es el año me tóxico lo
dibujaré por aquí aquí tenemos un
oxígeno un ch 3 y tenemos una carga
formal negativa en el oxígeno entonces
el núcleo fi lo ataca al carbón o
parcialmente positivo que tenemos aquí
nuestro núcleo fi lo ataca al electro
filo y al mismo tiempo perdemos el grupo
saliente y en este caso el ión bromuro
es el mejor grupo saliente entonces
estos electrones se van con el bromo
para formar el ion bromuro y al mismo
tiempo formamos un enlace entre el
oxígeno y el carbono entonces este par
de electrones libres en el oxígeno
formaron este enlace y así es como
obtenemos nuestro producto ahora si
analizamos la estéreo química empecemos
del lado izquierdo
ya sabemos que este carbono es un centro
que irak
y asignamos la prioridad a los cuatro
grupos unidos a ese centro quiral como
el bromo tiene el número atómico más
alto tiene la prioridad número uno
seguido por el flúor que es el número
dos después el carbono es el número tres
y finalmente el hidrógeno tiene la
prioridad más baja es el número cuatro y
se encuentra lejos de nosotros así que
vamos en dirección contraria a las
manecillas del reloj por lo tanto en
nuestro compuesto inicial tenemos una
configuración ese y en nuestro producto
nuevamente este carbono es nuestro
centro quiral pero esta vez cuando
asignamos las prioridades
el flúor tiene el número atómico más
alto seguido por el oxígeno después
sería el carbono y después claro tenemos
el hidrógeno así que también vamos en
esta dirección por lo que la
configuración sigue siendo ese entonces
este es un ejemplo de un mecanismo sn 2
en el que el núcleo filo ataca del lado
puesto al grupo saliente así que aún no
ocurre la inversión en términos del
mecanismo pero no ocurre una inversión
en la configuración en el producto por
como asignamos la prioridad de nuestros
grupos en este caso cuando el bromo se
va el flúor se convierte en el grupo de
mayor prioridad y por eso la
configuración sigue siendo s